okay it's time for some boxing gloves
table tennis bad
[Music]
Hey look uh actually God won't stay
there
[Music]
I think it's time for you also to take
it let's see how it goes just a normal
packet what else than a lucky point and
you get a lot of side spin yes in the
next episode we're gonna take challenges
from Instagram comments so if you
haven't followed us there yet
time to do that and we've also got a lot
of exclusive stuff that you guys so go
check out so the next challenge is to
play with 50 kilogram dumbbell so let's
hit the chip oh there we go
over 700 47 gonna lift up that's it
that's almost as heavy as me so here we
have it guys for the seven and a half
kilograms so it's us Oh 100 pounds I
think this the heaviest racket I've ever
played with
[Music]
yes you are I would cheer now but I
can't
[Music]
Oh almost happens
let's make us turn to try I think
someone's gonna get hurt just don't drop
it no I want I've got a bit different
approach
[Music]
No
oh my I went for the short one so next
we'll have a visiting star in this
episode is the boss of table tennis
Adam Barbara let's go play some rallies
nice
oh that post and in
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
did I make pong Finity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh beautiful alright if you enjoyed this
video and you haven't subscribed to pong
infinity subscribe here or watch their
other fun videos here or here
and if you want to see more of a demean
action go check out these channel here
till next time